I think charity and volunteering is
important and it is on my list of things
to do I just haven't gotten around it's
hard to classify yourself as like good
or bad I'm super broke so yeah I'm not
able to do anything like donate tons of
money you know you want to give back and
you want to like help people out but you
just get busy what do we just like
entertain them instead we can use our
natural talent our natural chemistry
heat the twenty you use it for gas on
the way home are you gonna want to split
it up or are we gonna just use it on one
I think we should this should be a
conjointly I still like the board game
idea no one is playing board games with
you okay fine
hi you can we brain abuse it improv for
you you're gonna go no problem all right
I think the best thing to do whoa is by
those people over there tacos meters we
are gonna fill the meters with quarters
and be later fairies hey guys we want to
buy your tarios whatever what you want
on us today now I got it in the chips
you up
then we do some improv for you while you
wait for this for the beautiful green
light
no improv we're doing improv on the
streets wait wait let us pray for you
hey you know what for the person who
comes after you look at that yes coming
like that thank you
but now I get there on their welcome
just a glass down that you have to admit
that this isn't really working 100% we
were escaping from how easy was that you
know my red noses so many of them too
let's go hand these babies out hey hello
giving her a radio sir heading childhood
poverty ah you do red noses Oh boom
each other probably one note at a time
well it's nice to have these red noses
because it makes people happy and it
made us happy and also like ghosts
toward ending child poverty you don't
have to think of being a good person in
such a big scale really don't need that
much time just more money more money
yeah maybe just take out five minutes of
your day to stop by and just like hey I
got this for you today we met some
people made some new friends handing out
noses
and that's a wrap
[Applause]